if you look at certain areas solar
panels solar technology generally
batteries electric vehicle
technology
semiconductors other parts of the supply
chain we have in america over the past
several decades
just watched our domestic supply chain
vanish before our eyes
when president-elect biden called me to
ask me to do the job
we talked about
being domestically focused
and rebuilding from within which by the
way we think is
the best way to be competitive globally
so it's about
investing in
talent
investing in research and development
making sure that we can compete globally
by having stronger technology
internally in america in the uh domestic
agenda are there areas where you think
you know this would be a great area you
know that chinese investment might work
that might help we are
at this point experiencing kind of good
collaboration with the chinese as it
relates to climate so i think that that
is an area where our goals are aligned
and we know that in order to hit the
president's president biden's climate
change
targets
we're heavily dependent on technology
like with the technology necessary to
hit his climate goals doesn't exist
today i can't emphasize this enough
on a case-by-case basis it depends on
who is the investor is their state
involvement what are their goals and we
are
serious
about protecting our national security
let me ask you kind of how you come to
your thinking about international trade
and china in particular as i understand
it your father used to work at bulova
was laid off with chinese competition
you were the governor and you were the
treasurer at a time when the custom
jewelry industry got clobbered by
chinese competition so how much does
that kind of factor into the way you
think about things i think significantly
you know that was my personal story it
was really hard right and rhode island
like so many places in the midwest in
the 80s 70s was like a vibrant
manufacturing economy and there was a
job there for everybody and then it all
went away in search of cheap labor to
china cheap labor drove out
manufacturing
so the president is committed to
bringing that back to america as am i
it's a big part of my story in fact
when i was thinking about taking the job
it was a hard decision and i called my
brother
and i said you know the president wants
me to do this and he said gina dad would
be so proud if you could play a role in
getting manufacturing going again in
america so
for me it's a huge motivator would you
imagine taking
delegations of ceos or senior
business officials abroad you know to
look at export or even investment
opportunities is that something you
think you would do yes absolutely a big
part of my job is
export promotion and i'm i'm looking for
example we're launching a clean tech
export promotion initiative we really
want to
do a do a better job helping american
businesses export their clean technology
any place that i see market interference
by
state actors or other governments or
unfairness or an unlevel playing field
for american companies trying to access
global markets that is definitely a huge
part of my job to kind of you know stick
up for american industry would china be
one of the places you imagine taking you
expect to take ceos i think so yes once
travel opens asia and china are very
important markets obviously a part of my
day every day is talking to american
businesses the chinese market is huge
uh and growing
and so and they don't play by the rules
they're not living up to their phase one
purchase commitments
uh they rip off our intellectual
property there's all kinds of
barriers that they're putting in place
which prevent american businesses from
accessing that market
so i plan to be a
forceful advocate on behalf of american
business and yes to ramp up our direct
engagement
with my counterparts in china and bring
businesses there
so it doesn't sound like you
agree with the idea of the two economies
decoupling
absolutely not i don't really think
that's an option i mean the size and
scale
of their economy is such that
we need access to that market and they
need and want access to this market so
we need robust commercial engagement
with china
that does not in any way ever
compromise our national security this
administration has talked about
cooperation in some areas like climate
do you think then in the trade and
economic area we're in it in the
cooperation basket or the let's just say
confrontation basket
a little of both you know cooperation is
the goal but we can't um we can't be
taken advantage of right so if they're
going to block our companies if they're
going to flood our market with
cheap steel and aluminum which hurts our
steel and aluminum industry if they're
going to
[Music]
not respect
protection of intellectual property
well then we'll be confrontational when
we need to be
but
also we need to do business there you
know and that's something that i think
is it's just an economic fact it's
complex and it is fraught
communication helps i think a lot of
communication helps i actually think
robust commercial engagement will help
to
mitigate any
potential tensions you know if we could
continue our commercial engagement
it it will help prevent unintended
conflict which can come from lack of
communication
you